is without fear of prosecution in the
Scottish Parliament but we're doing more
than that because what we're saying is
this is about power not just to the
parliament this is about power to the
Scottish people and to the people of
Britain and double Devolution means that
we are calling for the election of local
uh mayors of Province and at the same
time we're calling for the Devolution of
many of the functions from Edinburgh
where it is far too centralized to the
communities of Scotland which best know
what their needs are and so you see
these is a stronger Scotland in a
transformed United Kingdom and just
think of it this way that the ground is
now shifting in the debate about the
future in Scotland you know in 2014 I
had so many people saying I'm voting for
Independence because I don't think
there's any other alternative to change
Scotland or to change Britain now we
have an alternative now we have a set of
proposals that are groundbreaking that
can actually show we can make a
difference so the debate is no longer
between the state let us call an
independence the debate is no longer
between yes and no the bet is no longer
between change and no change the debate
is between change within the United
Kingdom led by the labor party and
changed by leaving the United Kingdom
which would not benefit Scotland under
the Scottish national party and just
I'm just
and just in conclusion think of it this
way the Scottish national party may want
to fight the election
with a one-line Manifesto the Scottish
national party may want it to be a
one-issue election instead of a general
election
we will do the opposite we will fight on
the social economic political and
constitutional change that we will bring
about in Scotland and across the United
Kingdom we will fight on jobs on the
Health Service on the future of
technology we will fight on the
environment we will fight on all these
issues and we will show
that the best way of standing up for
Scotland is by voting labor and voting
for kirstama the next prime minister of
the United Kingdom
thank you
[Applause]
I think Gordon I think the heavy lifting
has been done by you and your team and
uh I think it's gone down pretty well I
want to go to care first we're going to
have a conversation this afternoon here
this is potentially transformative to
the UK
um do you want to say a bit more about
um what your hopes are from Gordon's
commission yes please can I start by
thanking Gordon on the commission for
all their work because it's a fantastic
piece of work that they've put a huge
amount of effort into for the best part
of two years and I want to be absolutely
clear that I asked Gordon to do this
piece of work because I've long thought
that one of the things that's holding us
up as a United Kingdom is the hoarding
of too much power at the center and I
think that's held us up politically with
people across the whole of the United
Kingdom including here in Scotland
feeling that Westminster and Whitehall
are remote that you can't influence
what's going on there's not enough
control over communities and life where
people are and it can economically
because the single biggest failure of
the last 12 years in Westminster has
been the failure to grow the economy
sufficiently and I profoundly believe
that amongst the reasons for that is
that we have not used the talent and
resources of all parts of the United
Kingdom including here in Scotland
that's been hardwired into my political
thinking for a long time it's there in
my conference speeches it's there in the
speech I did on the economy earlier this
year and that's why after discussions
with Gordon I said would you set up this
commission and Report practical
recommendations about the biggest
Evolution the biggest movement of power
and resource and decision making away
from Whitehall and Westminster to ensure
that we can answer both the political
question of our time and the economic
question of our time and we can go
beyond that to build a New Britain and a
new economy within a New Britain and I'm
Delight excited today to be able to
launch the report alongside Gordon and
to warmly welcome everything that is in
it and we will now go on to consult on
refinement on testing and crucially on
implementing the recommendations and I
want to say two things about that
because in the report itself and in
discussions Gordon and I have had we
made it clear that we wanted
recommendations capable of being
implemented in the first term of a labor
government and the reason I want to do
consultation now is because I want that
consultation particularly about
implementation to be complete by the
time we get to the election so that when
we get elected in as I hope we do uh
sometime in the next two years we will
be a government about delivery we will
not be a government that is Consulting
at that stage it's very important that
you know we understand we're going to
inherit a United Kingdom whose politics
and whose economy are badly damaged and
we will need to be hit the ground
running and to do this from day one so
I'm delighted to take all of the
recommendations forward on that basis I
think it's an important compelling case
for change across the whole of the
United Kingdom but it is also a
compelling case for change here in
Scotland I thoroughly endorse what
Gordon has just said about being now
able to take the argument on to say it's
not changed by leaving the United
Kingdom versus the status quo it's
change within the United Kingdom that is
the alternative a stronger Scotland
within a changed United Kingdom and it's
really important to me that we can now
take that argument forward at the next
general election and we will set out in
our Manifesto our missions what we seek
to achieve as an incoming labor
government and then we will have a
mandate to carry that out in government
I look forward to therefore Consulting
on the recommendations turning that into
a concrete Mission winning that general
election and bringing about the change
in the United Kingdom and here in
Scotland that we desperately need we've
been desperately needing for a very very
long time so Gordon thank you very much
for all of your work I think this now
makes it absolutely clear that the
argument that we want to make about the
future of the United Kingdom of course
draws on our history of the things we've
done in the past but is much more about
the future than it is about the past
it's where we go from here as I say a
stronger Scotland within a changed
United Kingdom and I'm really really
pleased that we've been able to launch
this report today thank you Gordon and
thank you Sarah
thank you
I mean I think it's great to hear that
commitment from you here that actually
this is going to be part of the day job
and I think that's absolutely critical
for us in Scotland because we've seen
the Tories riding Russia over Devolution
and I also want to come to you first um
how do you think we can make this work
to end the binary divisive political
conflict Scotland has really suffered
between yes and no for the last few
years in Scotland how do we use this as
a stronger Scotland in a transformed UK
thank you sir I can first of all repeat
the thanks for to Gordon that the kid
has just done for an incredible piece of
work and demonstrating the the depth the
knowledge the ideas that will truly
transform our UK and as Kira said
strengthened Scotland and he reformed
changing modernizing United Kingdom but
I also want to thank cure directly as
well because let's be honest for 12
years in Scotland people haven't
believed that we could deliver a labor
government and therefore deliver change
that's the difference with this report
people believe a labor government is
possible people know there is a better
way of doing things and that will be
delivered by kirstarmer as our prime
minister and the first term of a labor
government led by a cure that's a
transformative change the third point to
make is this also breaks away from that
SMP impression that somehow anger
frustration disconnect and
discontentment only exist in Scotland
actually that anger disconnect and
discontentment is in Edinburgh it's in
Glasgow but it's also a Liverpool
Birmingham Manchester Cardiff and that's
why this is a plan that yes strengthened
Scotland but it also pushes power out
from Westminster to the Nations and
regions of every part of our United
Kingdom that means reforming the House
of Lords that means giving greater
transparency and accountability on the
House of Commons it means greater
responsibility for the Scottish
Parliament but it also means greater
control for local authorities local
government here in Scotland because for
too long we've had power sucked out of
our communities as centralized into
Hollywood that is a plan that is for
every part of our country the other
point to make is for too long the
argument has been that it is somehow the
status quo versus leaving the United
Kingdom the reality in Scotland right
now is there's not a majority in favor
of a referendum there's not a majority
in favor of Independence but neither is
their majority for the state is cool but
there is a vast majority in Scotland and
across the UK for change labor is that
change to deliver people across the
country and the change we're offering is
not just to answer your point directly
Sarah the change we're offering is not
just constitutional change we are
offering Democratic renewal social
renewal and economic renewal so people
can have yes more say or more control
their lives but we can also see a labor
government lifting people out of poverty
re-strengthening and growing our economy
and bringing our Public Services into
yes the 21st century but also preparing
them for the 22nd century that's what's
on offer in this campaign and that's why
we're hungry for the general election in
Scotland in Scotland labor no longer
fears an election we are enthused
energized and ready for a general
election because Scotland's going to
lead the way in electing a labor
government and making Kirsten
[Applause]
I don't know what to bring you in
because on one level we treat Devolution
as the norm and our aspiration in
Scotland but this is really radical for
the rest of the UK as well do you want
to say a bit more about that because I
think for many in England these are
really different proposals to what
they've experienced in the past a much
more centralist approach and do you want
to say a bit more about the radical
stuff you have in here about English
Divas just think of what's happening
around the whole of the United Kingdom
people now know that the new jobs
they're not going to come from a British
deal they're not going to come from
multinationals only they're going to
come from local companies that have new
technologies have World beating products
are Innovative and can show that they're
internationally competitive and what we
identified in this report and it hasn't
yet come out in the way and I hope
you'll read it is nearly 300 hot spots
economic clusters around the country in
life sciences and Medicine in
environmental renewable Technologies in
in digital and Ai and all these other
areas and in the created Industries and
they're all around the whole of the
United Kingdom and they're in Scotland
and they're in Wales and they're in
different parts of England and what they
need is locally sensitive policies so
that they can invest in the training and
skills that they need they need the
local job center and it needs to be
working for them and not for some
Central Authority they need training and
skills so they need the Devolution of
the colleges into the local areas they
need research and development so they
need this new British Regional and
National Investment Bank and what you
see from all of the different parts of
the United Kingdom Tracy brabham spoke
brilliantly today in Yorkshire as the
mayor of West Yorkshire only Burnham and
Manchester Jimmy uh in in Newcastle
you've got Steve Rotherham in Liverpool
all over the country what they're saying
is give us a post so that we can create
the jobs of the future so that we can
build the economy of the future and as
the same in Scotland there needs to be
Devolution from Edinburgh out to the
rest of Scotland as well but the
important thing is we're all talking
about the same thing changing the United
Kingdom making it more sensitive to
local needs making it deliver for people
not just in Scotland Wales but in the
whole of the United Kingdom and that's
why we'll see that there'll be great
support across every part of the United
Kingdom supporting Scotland's Ambitions
supporting Wales as Ambitions and
supporting the regional Ambitions in
England that's the change that we've
seen in the last few years and that's
the change that we identify in the
report but I tell you it means a million
new jobs around the country if we can
get these clusters of economic activity
the support they need to develop as
major industries of the future Scotland
position mentioned I said but there's so
many other Industries around Scotland
that will be uh memorable in the future
just as shipbuilding steel and coal was
memorable in the past because they will
get the support that they need from the
policies that we are proposing to pursue
this is such an important point about
the economic clusters because this is an
answer the question why have we not been
able to grow the economy over the last
decade or more and that is profoundly
because we haven't done it across the
whole United Kingdom wherever you go and
loads of people in the audience will
have seen this wherever you go whatever
the place is there is local ambition
there is local Brilliance Innovation
business
Etc but we've never transformed it into
clusters for the economy of the future
and that's what this report is all about
it's actually a report which in years to
come people will look back at and say
that was the turning point between an
old economy that wasn't working and a
new economy that actually has worked for
the whole of the United Kingdom so these
clusters are absolutely important and
that's why we've got to be really bold
about what we push away from Whitehall
and Westminster because I profoundly
believe that those with skin in the game
know best what works in their place and
in their community and the decisions
about people should be made as close to
where they are so they can influence
them as possible and that that takes
courage and so as we come into
governments I hope we will our first act
as it were will be to push that power
the biggest transfer of power away from
the center to where it should be and
it's not giving up power it's putting
power back where it should be so that
the economy can be turned on its held
and the new economy can emerge in that
way
around Scotland visiting businesses
talking to trade unions a huge ambition
to tackle that economic inequality do
you want to see a bit more about how we
get that double Devolution of Scotland
as well so one example of the economic
clusters think about the jobs first
transition we need we have been promised
now for 15 years a Green Revolution who
can remember the promise of the Saudi
Arabia of Renewables that just hasn't
been delivered through action from a UK
government that recognizes the need to
put our energy transition front and
center of our economy we can get
hydrogen in the Northeast we can finally
do carbon capture right we can transform
our green jobs Revolution here in
Scotland and therefore lead the way
again in Scotland but demonstrate
leadership across the rest of the UK and
in terms of the double Devolution look
we're in the City of Edinburgh where
they have seen firsthand the consequence
of a government that sucks power and
resource out of the council doesn't
starve our resources and then points the
finger of blame can you imagine if we
had Edinburgh with greater power greater
responsibility working in partnership
with its other local authorities what
more it could do to drive the East Coast
Economy the exact same in Glasgow where
they could do to drive the west of
Scotland economy and Aberdeen and Dundee
what they could do to drive the
Northeast economy that's what we mean by
double Devolution pushing power out of
our parliaments and into the hands of
local people yeah and I can see the
counselors not in their heads
I could see coach for Tammy D is very
happy with that I think that respect I
mean it's both respect for Scotland but
also within Scotland and we've not seen
so much of that and can I pick up one of
the points you made right at the start
Gordon about
um labor being the party of devolution
and the need to entrench that Devolution
to actually you know to tackle the
problem we've had with the Tories riding
Russia overdue Evolution do you want to
say a bit more about that because for me
that's one of the exciting yeah one of
the things that's happened and Kimmy
wished to comment on this as well over
the last few years particularly after
2016 was that the conservatives have
undermined the Devolution settlement
instead of what was called the Sewell
convention that they were traditionally
not interfere with areas that were
devolved to Scotland and Wales they've
ridden Russia over it and what we want
to do is to ensure that we can say to
the people of Scotland that the
Devolution settlement will be entrenched
and that no government can easily just
remove it or undermine it or just take a
it away and that's why we propose that
the new second chamber if it is
democratic
it will lose its power to hold up
legislation for for a year
but it will gain a part to uphold the
Constitutional rules of the United
Kingdom and that includes and will be
Central to it is the Devolution
settlement so what we're envisaging is a
new kind of constitution I mean I mean
as you know um in America there are a
hundred Senators for 30 million people
and in Britain there are now 830 Lords
for 65 million people and both are
second Chambers and it just doesn't seem
right for the future so we reform the
house of House of Lords but we make it a
second chamber that is representative of
the regions and nations with the duty to
uphold the Devolution settlement I know
it's quite exciting because it's really
a bit modernizing the UK isn't it here
yeah I think this is really important
because as Gordon there's been a lot of
discussion about
um what we do with the House of Lords
and abolition but it's very important
um that alongside abolition there is to
be a second chamber and that has a
Central purpose which is to safeguard
Devolution and other constitutional
issues and that is an important part of
the change that we want to bring about
so it's not just abolition it's
abolition second chamber and repurpose
but that's part of a wider ambition
which is to ensure that all four nations
have more of a say in what we do that's
the whole point of the council for
Regions and Nations to make sure there
are those powerful voices and I think
Gordon uh if there's the shul convention
but I think there's also even in covid
we saw the government in Westminster
disrespecting Scotland not bringing
Scotland in nor actually saying any duty
to cooperate and work as as one group of
four and I think that in the report he
is therefore not just this business of
the house laws becoming custodians but
going a lot further than that I think
the stuff also on International treaters
it's all really important in relation to
the influence and power and strength of
voice that Scotland and the other
nations have you know I think there's a
bit about parliamentary accountability
which you know is often discarded both
in Scotland and at the UK level and I
ask you what to come you've also you've
got two governments you've got a tour of
government and an SMP government who
actually make a virtue out of conflict
because actually neither of them believe
in Devolution and actually making a
virtue of cooperation is really really
important that's about respecting
people's Authority respect in the
Democratic rate that they have so
respecting the roles of our Mayors
respecting the rules of our first
ministers repeating the roles of our
Parliament but that respect has to go
two ways and through cooperation I think
we can achieve so much more and that's
the plan here to strengthen Scotland's
status of course give strong Scotland a
stronger voice but also recognizing that
the UK works for us across the UK when
it works and also reform it transform it
and modernize it ready for the rest of
the 21st century yeah so timing timing
is everything in politics isn't it so
we've got this plan now
um can you do you want to say a bit
about where we go next you're saying
we're going to Manifesto consultation
this is real stuff now isn't it yeah
this is a really comprehensive report I
hope some of you have had the chance to
read it or get the chance to read it
because it is a compelling set of not
just a report but set of recommendations
ready to be taken forward to the next
stage which is
um that consultation now the
consultation isn't just a sort of vague
exercise it's a statement of intent as
far as I'm concerned which is if this is
to move from recommendations to
implementation it is very important that
we're serious about how we Implement and
that means we need to have discussions
with those affected by the
recommendations being implemented to
make sure we're in a position to
um you know take action immediately we
get into power so that's the purpose of
the consultation I don't want an
incoming labor government to be in the
business of carry out consultations what
labor governments be coming in to carry
out the change that is vitally necessary
for our country and I invite everybody
um you know whether they voted yes or no
whether they vote whether they live in a
town or city or wherever they are across
the United Kingdom to be part of that
discussion about implementing these
recommendations because we know that it
is the delivery of this change that
matters there's plenty of discussion
about change this is actually a
compelling case not just for change but
how you bring about that change and it
will be the mission of the next Labor
government actually deliver on that and
that's why we want to have this
discussion from now until we put the
manifesto together and go into that
general election
that's the case that I'm talking there
in Edinburgh about Plans by labor for a
democratic second chamber an elected
house to replace the House of Lords that
he said will be representative of the
Regency speaking there alongside the
former labor prime minister Gordon Brown
who is the author of the report on which
these recommendations are based and and
I saw were the Scottish labor leader the
MSP alongside them as well let's bring
our political correspondent Joe Pike
he's in in Edinburgh for us and
following this story today Gordon Brown
answer Keystone Joe um very keen to
stress that this would be change for
Scotland without them leaving the UK
they've claimed that Sarah Jane
certainly but if you look at the detail
and read the report there isn't a huge
amount about Scotland not as if there's
some a huge section of of powers to be
devolved from Westminster to Hollywood
that doesn't seem to be happening in
fact the plan seems to be too
decentralized from Nicholas sturgeon's
government here in Scotland's capital to
councils perhaps getting Metro Mayors in
Greater Glasgow and in Edinburgh and the
lothians as we already have in Greater
Manchester and in the West Midlands I
was in the room for some of that event
and interesting to see how Scottish
labor events seem to be changing as
power is potentially on the horizon I've
been to a lot of these events in recent
years they're often slightly sparse the
attended that is it was a very different
event because perhaps there was a sniff
of power of uh parliamentary seats and
of jobs in government even now the
reason the labor party are holding a
event now at Edinburgh after the one
earlier in Leeds it's partly because of
Gordon Brown where he's from what he
cares about but also because labor
getting into government requires some
progress north of the border at the last
election they started with seven seats
with the election went back down to one
one uh when the SMP have 48. so labor
duty to build up support in places like
Edinburgh as well as Glasgow five
perhaps pick up East lodia one of their
old seats this is a big bold ambitious
plan not a huge amount of detail a
critics argue and there's also the get
out clause that KIA stammer said he will
consult he wants that consultation on
all these issues to be over by the next
election so they can put a lot of it
into place of course that will depend
how big a Labor's majority is if they do
win the next election certainly
criticism today from other parties the
conservatives arguing labor is playing
politics with issues that don't matter
to the the country but only obsessed
those in Westminster as for the SMP as
SMP the Scottish national party led by
Nicola sturgeon they are arguing that
today is Groundhog Day that it's another
example of Gordon Brown with promises
over the Constitution that they doubt
will be delivered of course the reason
people are suddenly interested in a
labor Devolution plan Sarah Jane is
because labor getting into government
Lisa Westminster does now seem possible
this stuff could happen even though as I
say Kia style has given himself a little
bit of wiggle room on this issue